voilà des mois que la vie de loana est
jonché d'obstacles que la jeune femme
semble avoir de plus en plus de mal à
surmonter dominé par ses addictions
après plusieurs rechutes et un séjour en
hôpital psychiatrique
voilà que la starlette a été une
nouvelle fois retrouvée inconsciente à
son domicile parisien
ce sont les pompiers prévenus par le
propriétaire de l'appartement qu'elle
occupe qui sont venus au secours de
loana le 26 mars dernier et retrouvée
inconsciente elle a été transportée
d'urgence à l'hôpital
en cause une crise très importante de
somnifère n'est pas de produits
stupéfiants selon les premières analyses
de son côté eric breier son meilleur ami
a pris la parole sur facebook en
accusant une nouvelle fois sylvie ortega
nous les vrais amis loana essayons de la
protéger malheureusement une salle
balance tout aux médias et n'hésite pas
à se servir des malheurs de loana pour
faire parler d'elle
loana est prise en charge et va bien
alors lohan a de nouveau dans le coma
que s'est il passé
laurent qui a retrouvé loana inanimé est
avec nous pour tout nous raconter
eh oui loana donc vendredi soir inanimé
loana ça a été un truc de fou au
vendredi soir que monique tout le monde
m'a appelé j'ai reçu des mails de
personnes que je connaissais pas pour me
dire est ce qu'on peut avoir des
nouvelles de loana est ce qu'on peut
aller chercher luan à ce que vous
connaissez la personne chez qui est
loana et l'auront ce galeux merci d'être
avec nous notre propriétaire du airbnb
où vivait loana c'est vous qui l'avez
qui avait découvert la la star inanimé
merci d'être là merci beaucoup l'ont et
eryl prayer est avec nous bien sûr
meilleure amie de loana vous avez donné
des nouvelles et surtout guillaume
genton on va essayer aussi trouvé avec
bien sûr il a des solutions parce que
c'est vrai que à chaque fois on se dit
voilà on dit qu elle nous dit qu'elle va
mieux et on voit que voilà ça va pas
mieux du tout donc donner des infos je
sais que vous avez pas mal d'infos et je
pense que là il faut vraiment qu'elle
soit quelqu'un ne peut pas rester tout
seul en vendredi on apprend tout ce que
loana est dans un état grave un
guillaume genton oui absolument pour
recontextualise un peu donc elle était
sortie de l'hôpital d'hyères dans le sud
les médecins lui ont recommandé de
rester dans le sud est malgré les
recommandations des médecins et les
remonter à paris elle a fait une
réservation airbnb pour 35 me je crois
que c'était un certain nombre de temps à
paris elle était seule dans cet
appartement elle vit avec son ami
nicolas elle s'était retrouvée seule
donc elle a été retrouvée par par
monsieur auquel est repartie elle
habitait seule elle vivait seul et tout
le monde lui disait y compris ses amis
de ne pas retourner à paris parce que
c'était mauvais pour elle parce que
paris c'est comme la ville des
tentations défaite même si on a moins en
ce moment où elle se retrouver seul à la
fin
c'est là où elle fait face à ses
addictions notamment et c'est vrai
qu'elle est dans un cadre beaucoup plus
favorable pour elle dans le sud
et là il ya un peu retourné contre
l'avis de tout le monde et rive je me
permets d'intervenir en fait l'histoire
c'est que nico m'a téléphoné à mon
meilleur ami voilà avec nico avec
qu'hier la nuit voilà à cannes nico
m'appelle me dit j'ai toujours travaillé
au luxembourg ça m'ennuie de laisser
loana tout seul est ce que tu peux la
récupérer chez toi j'ai dit oui a pas de
problème elle vient la maison une
chambre d'amis aucun problème sauf que
nico mas pangée le coronavirus non amer
donc j'ai dit ah oui et loana bas je
pense qu'elle va la voir aussi avec ma
maman qui a 92 ans d'ailleurs je te
souhaite un joyeux anniversaire maman
parce que c'est commence à devenir
assurément marie marie bourland brasse
mari voilà donc c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui comme ella âgée j'ai dit à
loana je suis désolé mais moi je prends
pas de risques
ma mère a rappelé coronavirus âgées plus
qu'acheter une tombe donc donc voilà
donc s'applique à ce qu'elle a fallu
monter à paris ok alors laurent merci
déjà d'être là c'est donc vendredi que
laurent comment ça s'est passé vous avez
pourquoi vous avez été dans
l'appartement en fait vous a dit qu'il y
avait un problème qu'est ce qui se passe
vendredi soir non alors en fait elle a
fait une réservation ou au nom de sylvie
ortega ont mois thierry le 16 février
pour à peu près cinq semaines donc c'est
sylvie ortega rodez lui qui a fait la
réservation du airbnb donc vous ne
saviez pas que c'est loana booth a dit
qu'il était silver pega ou pas du tout à
l'époque ce février non parce que je
pense que c'était avant les histoires
qui a eu ici à gauche vous avez
découvert après que c'est c'est après
quand on fait ou on employé m'a dit la
cliente qui dans son appartement elle
veut prolonger d'un mois
d'accord la voir donc la semaine
dernière j'ai été la voir vous êtes
tombés sur je suis tombé sur loana
adacore away et donc à ce moment là bas
j'ai échangé avec elle des sms deux
jours après elle m'apprend qu'elle est
là mais les renforts mais non elle élève
un enfant d'accord non très bien vous
avez dû et si vous l'avez laissé le
airbnb en bois de plus ça ça sa
réservation se terminer la semaine
dernière d'accord donc à partir de
mercredi elle m'a dit je vais te payer
on est géré c'est un mois de plus
d'accord mercredi dernier je les ai vues
elles n'étaient pas du tout en forme
elle tremble elle avait du mal à trouver
les clés et m'a demandé de lui ouvrir sa
porte
jamal el kobbi de face et scandalisé
parce qu'elle m'a dit qu'elle avait le
coït donc j écoute le recul toit je peux
pas trop m'approcher bonjour ouvert la
porte et j'ai laissé mon mais elle
tremble elle était pas bien le jeudi je
lui envoie des messages elle me répond
pas je l'appelle ne répond pas à vendre
y est pareil donc vendredi soir vers 20
heures
je me suis permis d'aller voir mais
alors j'ai frappé d'accord ouais j'ai
sonné j'entendais le chien aboyer la
télé allumée mais elle ouvrait pas donc
je suis permis d'ouvrir et je les ai
trouvé allongé sur le canapé lit la
bouche ouverte
[Musique]
dénudée presque
donc je vais lucas respirer j'ai
toujours appelé les pompiers
ils m'ont dit vous pouvez la mettre sur
le côté
j'écoutais à l'alcool id je vois qu'elle
respire donc l est pas c'est ça la
respire donc ça va mais je me vois pas
trop de la touche et on puisse y aller
pas habillé bon donc ils sont arrivés
très vite dès qu'ils sont arrivés ils
ont tout de suite
remuez elle s'est réveillée halte s'est
demandé où elle était parce que les
pompiers tabbee en plus sans eux
avec la combinaison anti rides elle
avait du mal à trouver ses mots à
trouver des réponses à la date de
naissance des choses comme ça donc elle
avait perdu connaissance alors je sais
pas quand même sens et a duré
il y avait là les prix des médicaments
est quelque chose qu'on a des infos
apparemment elle se serait pas drogué
l'auraient peut donc c'est justement
j'ai trouvé banques parce que c'est
difficile pour elle mais apparemment ne
sera pas de rigueur j'ai trouvé aucune
drogue dans l'appartement beaucoup de
boîtes de médicaments
voilà c'est ça mais il y avait de tout
ça partait de l'aspirine à des
antibiotiques mais j'ai trouvé aucune
drogue
en tout cas dans l'appartement alors
éric là aujourd'hui encore on se demande
tous comment elle va loana est ce qu a
eu des nouvelles depuis vendredi
non moi j'ai pas de nouvelles parce
qu'en fait elle a passé téléphone
portable à vittel a dû aller à l'hôpital
actuellement je pense qu'à l'hôpital ou
encore mangez retrouver la trace du
chien si on avait perdu
je sais où est le chien donc demain je
vais essayer de récupérer le schéma qui
a dénoncé thor 6 pour le chien on m'a
dit qu'il était chez non le chien et au
commissariat je peux le dire il ya au
commissariat du 3e arrondissement donc
demain je vais faire un saut ont confié
monde sépare les premiers mondiaux est
ce que vous avez une personne à appeler
qui la connaît j'ai dit à écouter la
réservation et au nom si les gars je
crois qu'elles sont pas tellement un bon
terme à ce qui est dit mais par contre
je connais quelqu'un qui travaille avec
cyril d'accord en l'occurrence yann
d'accord j'ai appelé yann tout de suite
chez diane est ce que tu as tu peux
avoir numéro 2 avril d'accord et je
racontais l'histoire c'est là que j'ai
appelé pour le prévenir
d'accord d'accord va très bien grave et
voilà bravo à vous en tout cas parce que
vous avez ici à voilà à gérer l'histoire
aujourd'hui on le voit le canal va être
encore à l'hôpital
est-ce qu'on a des nouvelles de son état
gilles verdez bon alors elle va pas bien
je pense car il pourra le confirmer ça
va pas bien effectivement à priori c'est
une surdose médicamenteuse et elle s'est
sentie très seule ces derniers jours
juste avant c'est à dire qu'avec nicolas
dans le sud ça c'est pas super bien
passé faut le virer du lion
il ya eu des tensions avec nicolas donc
elle s'est dit si avec nicolas mon
meilleur ami en ce moment ça ne va pas
non plus avec qui ça va aller à les
remonter il ya eu un spleen à paris
effectivement dans ces cas là mais moins
que justement c'est comme jeudi à loana
pour redescendre la tension vient passer
quelques jours à la maison et ça ça
roder son attention après je te ramène à
cannes et on fait comme ça jusqu'à que
tu es ton petit appartement au dessus du
cabaret où tu pourras avoir ta petite
vie tranquille mais c'est le courant
navires us deux projets arrête de
projets de cabaret avec nicolas avec
nicolas alors là il ya eu des tensions
c'est vrai bon est-ce que c'est
irrémédiable ou pas en tout cas y avait
des tensions dans le match et voilà bien
souvent des tensions avec lui c'est un
peu volcanique compliqué
pas bien et on sait des petites tensions
mais honnêtement elle ne va pas bien
surdose médicamenteuse n'y avait pas de
drogue
elle n'a pas d'argent pas beaucoup
d'amis à paris lé les relations et que
sa maman néant
il ya plus de contacts en ce moment donc
c'est une femme très seule voie il faut
savoir que ce moment je les temps en
temps et régulièrement au téléphone elle
me demande des nouvelles de soft mais il
n'y a pas de contacts directs parler
savamment elle donc c'est avec ce qui
s'est passé elle a porté plainte jeudi
contre sa mère et violette est très
remonté là je me mets à la place des
téléspectateurs quand ils entendent tout
ça ils se disent mais a laissé la
solution parce qu'elle va ressortir à
l'hôpital naval seule la ligne à mais là
il ya un moment lamballe loisirs et
médecins ça va être ça va être
c'est peut-être là médecins qui ont une
responsabilité à l'hôpital a les pauvres
ils travaillent à oui maintenant alors
non non non là évidemment évidemment ça
fait beaucoup de peine de devoir ça
après ce qu'il faut dire c'est que c'est
une situation qui est extrêmement
compliqué vous dit qu'elle est seul
c'est vrai l'essonne ya aussi des gens
qui sont là pour elle hier il est à son
ami nicolas nous on lui tend la main
voilà en couture mois après après le
tout la promotion qui a vu le
documentaire je les ai aidés mais la
descente on devait se voir elle n'a plus
donné de nouvelles m'a dit qu'elle avait
le qu'ovide effectivement elle répond qu
aux appels donc c'est compliqué en fait
il faut qu elle aussi fasse un pas vers
ceux qui veulent l'aider et il en faudra
fini voilà et qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire ou non concrètement qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire je sers et argent ça
ne suffit pas l'amitié ça ne suffit pas
aider quelqu'un capable exact il ya des
moments ils se retrouvent seuls loana et
dans ces moments mais elle peut se
droguer potentiellement elle peut partir
comme elle l'a fait à paris alors que
tout le monde lui disait de rester dans
le sud donc c'est un cas qui est
extrêmement complexe socialement c'est
ça l'essentiel
est ce qu'elle a de nouveau des contacts
avec silver dégâts parce que c'est
sylvie ortega milan ac a loué le il y en
a eu récemment qu'avec des silver séguin
elle a démenti à 9h et laurent se galons
la la
j'ai eu un message de singer dégagé ben
oui ça c'est intéressant mais ça fait vu
l'état de l'appartement j'ai déposé une
plainte pour aider au dédommager de ce
qui s'est passé dans un appartement ce
qui est alors il était dans quel état
l'appartement dix boucles à très très
salll porcherie de l'uriné partout
aprilia le chien il y avait le chien qui
ne devait pas sortir beaucoup de la boue
partout donc vous avez porté plainte
j'ai pas porté plainte non non j'ai
juste demandé à être réparés par rapport
aux dégâts de l'appartement je peux pas
loué un appartement dans l'état où il
est d'accord donc c'est dommage sociaux
j'ai commencé à demander un
dédommagement silver tega voilà bah la
personne qui m'a loué l'appartement en
l'occurrence et silver ses galons la
réservation
qu'est ce que vous a dit elle m'a envoyé
un message en disant c'est irrespectueux
gym mais si quick qu'est-ce qui est
respectueux je dis moi j'ai sauvé la vie
de loana
je demande juste à voir être dédommagés
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
l'appartement je sais tout et d'elle
même envoyé un message sur un autre
appartement que je que je gère en me
disant voilà je suis si leurs dégâts
ex-agents de loana merci de me rappeler
l'aspect numéro je les appelais mais m'a
pas répondu
je lui ai laissé mon numéro de téléphone
m'a pas rappelée aucun dédommagement
pour vous je pense là ça va être sûrs en
dédommageant parce que des airbnb à un
fonds d'assurance donc quand on arrive
je région mais oui j'ai dû garder
c'est très troublant à un moment on a
même cru que sylvie ortega aurait pu
être entre guillemets abuser c'est à
dire que loana aurait pu louer
l'appartement en usurpant son identité
ce qu'elle a dit sylvie ortega qui ont
un rôle très bizarre et moi je vais vous
dire si luis ortega là elle commence à
m'exaspérer il ya quelque chose que je
n'admets pas quand il arrive un drame à
loana immédiatement il ya un petit un
petit organe médiatique est informé par
sylvie ortega je pense car il le sait et
moi ce qu'on m'a dit et là ce serait
honteux c'est que quand tu as un enfant
de cet organe de presse comme par hasard
elle toucherait un petit billet une
sorte de piges pour des informations
rétribués si c'est ça moi c'est mes
informations si c'est ça c'est immonde
on va lui demander si
franchement nous dira si c'est ça c'est
immonde parce que s'il dit on lui
demandera thoiras étaient rétribués sur
la mauvaise santé de loana
là je n'admettrai pas on le sera demain
cyril c'est ce que vous avez entendu
aussi oui tout à fait j'ai lu ça aussi
d'ailleurs dans la presse d'accord très
bien alors loana on va prendre des
nouvelles on va essayer de trouver des
solutions et bien sûr devant demandera
si dureté guerre si cette histoire est
vraie ou pas gilles verdez